Hàng Trung Nguyên Nguyên S Tình tại trên nha viết,
giữ rú xa lệm và nhiều khu bực khác, yêu cầu chính phủ đã thật thận đưa con tín trở về và chấm rất phía sự giải gà ra.
Nói đau của gia đình có người bị bắt sử kéo sài gần hai năm,
càng khiến xa cách giữa ẩn giá tăng, biểu tình bương nổ,
sau phát biểu tại lưu của của tụt từng mấy trời mình đi tàn gia hô,
hiệu chiến như tên một phần con tín.
Chúng khi đó, tại giải gà ra,
quân đối xa ra em thì tụt mở sống chiến dịch,
bộ ăn chim nghìn người dân phải sơ tảm, nhiều tòi nhà bị phá huy.
Tìm bộ cân sáng của giới chiến dịch ràn đưa ra mới đây khẩn định.
Nếu hà mắt không thả tòa tòa bộ công tín,
và không sả giáp, gà ra sẽ bị huy giết,
và hà mắt sẽ bị só sổ, càng làm càng thẳng lâu thang.
Không chỉ tại Israel là sống phần đối có lan xang anh được,
năm phi và nhiều uu xa khác.
Lên tởi hàng chim nghìn người tòa anh yêu cầu chứm giúp bạo lực,
nâng công cơm của khí cho Israel và báo đảm viện trở nhân đạo vào cơ ra.
Như độc thấy này phà nánh sử bắt đình xong giọng trong cộng đồng của tế,
trước cơ súng đột kéo sài.